i think that there are some normal
democrats
who look at what happened
on tuesday
and they see what happened frankly in
2016 as well with the election of donald
trump and they recognize that the
progressive movement
which
incorporates and includes i would say
much of the political media
and dominates the conversation on social
media especially twitter which is where
a lot of democratic politicians hang out
and seem to base their decisions on what
the twitter mob is saying
a lot of those folks even left of center
realize how destructive it is
and yet i don't know if the democrats
can pull themselves out of this problem
unless they are willing to acknowledge
the reality
that most people recognize in this
country
which is that wokeness and hardcore
progressivism and all of that
is alienating exhausting annoying
and yet
after the republicans ran an extremely
credible
issues-based campaign in virginia and
they won in a state that has gone blue
for the last decade and a half
republicans were shut out of statewide
office
for 12 years joe biden won it by 10
points and then the republicans run on
like kitchen table issues
they're talking about inflation glenn
young can talk about the grocery tax
people are looking around and seeing
what's happening the cost of things
going up shortages in labor shortages in
goods
and the republicans were responsive to
that to that talking about issues that
people actually care about and then of
course education
from school closures for more than a
year in virginia public schools thanks
to the democrat union alliance
to woke
curriculum points
racialized curricula
critical race theory political
correctness dumbing down standards
equity all of it
people saw what was going on they
noticed it that's what james carville
said in the last segment we played the
clip
where he said this stuff happens
and people see that that was his quote
but what the democrats
the hardcore democrats and especially
their activists their base and the media
what a lot of them want everyone to
believe the way that they rationalize
this the way that they explain away
their pain through more anger and more
smears and more dishonesty is to blame
voters
for being
a combination of racist and stupid
right so they want people to believe
that virginia which has gone their way
right virginia is great look at what
virginia's doing until virginia dares to
not vote democratic then all of a sudden
it's the old south
back again
racism right this is what they do it
just turns on a dime so they all of a
sudden virginia became racist again
all these parents
are racist
making up parental rights making up
critical race theory making up this
stuff that they are seeing with their
own eyes in their own lives and they are
being told shouted out
shouted at
by some of these media elites by the
activists that they're crazy they're
wrong they're racist
or and i think this one is almost as
insulting racist would be more insulting
if it still meant something except they
scream racist about everything all the
time it diminishes
that word
because the real thing right
the authentic phenomenon of racism is
abhorrent it is disgusting
it is appalling
and it's wrong
to over apply it
like the the genuine article is terrible
and should be stamped out when you see
it everywhere and claim that it's
everywhere you lose credibility and
people tune you out and then as i was
gonna say the second part is well maybe
these people aren't intentionally racist
but they're just duped
evil glenn younkin
invented
to quote barack obama the trumped-up
phony culture war
of critical race theory
which is not phony or trumped up it's
real
right or what the sexual assault in the
bathroom that was covered up in loudoun
county i guess that was phony and
trumped up even though that was horrific
and real
right they want us to believe that
people either have hate in their hearts
or they have been bamboozled
by these manipulative republicans to
believe that something really is
happening when it doesn't and when it
isn't
i mean what a way to try to win back
voters that you've lost to immediately
scream at them for being
[ __ ] racists that's what they're going
with
they're writing columns the return of
the racist white woman white women
shifted republican by 15 points in
virginia
and rather than saying gosh maybe we
should think about why we offended so
many mothers
why we offended so many female voters
if they're willing to call them that as
opposed to birthing people or voters who
menstruate
instead of doing that they said look at
these white
women
i mean white women am i right and all
the actors say
well let's all roll our eyes and shake
our heads together man white women it's
just racism that's what they're doing
here as a form of shaming
and they're actually learning none of
the actual lessons that led voters to
act the way that voters did not just
white voters
but a lot of hispanic voters and even an
increasing number over time of black
voters they don't want that to be
reckoned with they don't want to grapple
with that they don't want that reality
to intrude on
the way that they talk and they think
and they're really
i would say insidious toxic gross world
view and so what we get here's a montage
it's from grabian.com a montage of
cnn msnbc other lefty commentators
reacting to what happened in virginia
you know why the republicans won in
virginia
the republicans know why they won in
virginia
voters saw what happened they looked
around every day and they said we're not
happy with the way things are going
we're not happy with the democratic
party but what a lot of our colleagues
in the media see is something
much darker cut 23. glenn younkin played
the race card for a reason because he
knows it works on certain white voters
he did stoke white grievance politics to
mobilize the republican base he's
laundered trump's really sort of
disgusting flagrant out racism he's
wrapped it in education education right
which is code for
white parents don't like the idea of
teaching about race that's the
fundamental problem for these parents
and this anti-crt movement they don't
like the way whiteness is being
portrayed in these new more inclusive
lessons this wasn't about those
pocketbook issues this was about how
white kids feel talking about what black
kids go through the subtext of all this
was we can't let these black and brown
people run the country glenn younkin
running
on critical race theory that he knew hit
accord around race i think all the crt
stuff is trumped up dog whistling some
of it was
uh dog whistle racism
it's just amazing
and on and on there's a whole that was
57 seconds we've got another minute and
five of just oh all of it
whiteness whiteness i mean these people
are out of their minds
they are obsessed with skin color and
race it's really
bizarre
it's it's sad actually but it's also
scary
because these are the elites of society
who are driving the conversation of
course they're driving people away from
the democratic party into the open arms
of the republicans
who are willing to say no
we're not going to go along with this
racket
by the way i love that clip from what we
just played the snippet
the subtext of all this is we can't let
these black these black and brown people
run the country
that was one of the uh jewels
of glittering insight that we heard in
that montage it's a subtext we can't let
these black and brown people run the
country guess what
on the republican ticket in virginia
there was a black and a brown person
who will now be running the state
winsome sears is the first black woman
elected statewide ever in virginia a
black jamaican immigrant who came to
this country signed up for the marines
and said she was willing to die for this
country because this country is worth it
she also
ran a shelter for homeless women you
don't hear much about her in fact i saw
usa today had a story about all the
candidates of color making history
around the country great guess who they
left out
both of the republicans who won in
virginia to statewide office
then they updated their story after
people called them out on it this always
slipped their mind only the two
statewide officials in the most watched
state in the country this week who won a
black woman and hispanic man just didn't
make it into that story
and the wrong type of people of color
that's why you can have morons saying
dum-dum things like this is all about
making sure black and brown people don't
run things
literally
literally the people of virginia
republicans said we're going to pick a
woman of color and a hispanic ag
that's who we're going to pick to run
the state
and the takeaway from these geniuses who
sneer at you as an idiotic racist is
that
these republicans are just afraid of
black and brown people
you have to be
a total liar or just broken brained to
say that or just ignorant you have no
idea who is on the ticket
right you just say republican white bad
i mean the fact that they're talking
about whiteness as much as they are
i think belies the problem right they
all critical race theory it's all a lie
it doesn't exist they made this up it's
misinformation that's not true
we've told you over and over again
evidence why it's not true and it's also
again you cannot convince
an electorate that something totally
fabricated is happening without some
evidence
right we quoted in the washington post
latina mom a black dad concerned about
what they are seeing on the ground in
the schools in their communities right
there's a black dad saying his kids
brought home
an abraham lincoln assignment that
troubled him based on the racial angle
this is a black father so he started to
homeschool his kids because of the
indoctrination he didn't want his kids
to go through and these leftists say
it's all a lie this critical race theory
is a lie there this isn't happening and
then they turn right around and they
give the game away
by spouting all of this critical race
theory stuff they all believe it or
whether they believe it or not they say
it endlessly it is what their entire
world view is predicated on
racial grievance critical race theory
and all the buzzwords of equity and
anti-racism they're like this is crazy
this these idiotic racist parents in
virginia believe that there's all this
uh racialism in schools that isn't
happening these stupid racist liars by
the way this is about whiteness they won
because of whiteness like you guys are
doing the thing that you say doesn't
exist
you are doing the thing that you say
doesn't exist you go on msnbc you go on
cnn in front of tens of viewers and you
talk about whiteness and you rant about
race and dog whistling and all this
stuff you misconstrue things you lie
and then you treat people concerned
about exactly that same garbage being
taught in schools you say well that's
not even possible it's not happening
it's happening on your network right now
you're doing it you're doing it
and your ideological buddies in the
teachers unions are putting it into
schools that is what's happening and
that is what a lot of americans are fed
up about and that's why glenn younkin is
gonna be the governor of virginia and
not terry mcauliffe who called it all a
lie and campaigned with randy weingarten
okay
that's the wake-up call
and their solution apparently
is to call you all stupid misinformed
misinformation adult
racists
keep doing this honestly keep going with
this guys
can we drive even more people
out of the democratic party please
i mean look the republicans have their
problems and they drive me crazy and
there's some real flaws and problems in
the republican party believe me
but for the first time in a while i was
excited to vote for a candidate who was
glenn younkin in virginia as a virginia
voter because he's not the things that
they say he is and yet they just keep
saying it
and when you insult people's
intelligence over and over again
finally people get fed up with it
by the way nicole wallace on msnbc who's
just i mean
he was one of their anchors on election
night he was a
glenyakin
glenyonkin
insurrectionist
he flew an insurrection flag at his
rallies
it's like
made up
absolute lie
an absolute lie right they say what
republicans need to do is repudiate the
big lie and need to reject this stuff
younkin did that younkin did what they
say they want and what they turned
around and said was oh he didn't do that
and just made up stories about him
right who this glenn younkin he's in bed
with donald trump he is donald trump
he's basically donald trump in a vest
with a smile an extremist very dangerous
insurrection right all this stuff no one
believes it junkin doesn't campaign with
trump then mcauliffe invents a rally
that didn't happen
and these people all believe that you
are the problem you and your
misinformation are the problem
when they are proving the problem and
they are spouting misinformation
we had what is that yamiche alcindor
that journalist
she's just a left-wing activist
being paid by us because she works at
pbs she asked a question of
president biden it's not even a question
really
this was yesterday
she what is your message for democrats
democratic voters especially black
voters who see republicans running on
race as patton lying about critical race
theory and they're worried that
democrats don't have an effective way to
push back on that that's her question
about the republican lies on critical
race theory
i mean i could give a point-by-point
rebuttal as i have on this show because
this is the same lie that the democrats
tried and failed with in virginia but
this is a journalist paid for by
taxpayers asking a question really just
making a partisan statement
like i have no problem she can have
whatever opinion she wants
don't tell me she's a journalist and
don't make me pay her salary as a
journalist
oh and last but not least aoc rolling in
with her little video that she posted on
instagram or whatever this is so much
the problem in virginia you see
according to aoc is they were just too
moderate these democrats just running a
moderate campaign it's not going to work
yes aoc that's it first of all terry did
he strike you as a moderate the way he
was running no
screaming about you know abortion
defending late-term abortion bringing in
every left-wing democrat he could think
of into the state attacking parents
campaigning with randy weingarten if
that's a moderate campaign good luck
but if that's what she believes i think
aoc should campaign for every single
democrat in the country i want her in
all 50 states in 2022.
if you want hardcore progressivism to
win
put your money where your mouth is boots
on the ground aoc i want you there
supporting your fellow democrats and
maybe you'll do just as well as bernie
did in the primary or that socialist did
in buffalo when she lost to a write-in
candidate
or the defund the police failures in a
bunch of places the other night it's
delusional there's so much delusion and
on some level i welcome it we'll be
right back